in the closing arguments the depth
lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime and said you were acting
what do you say to that
says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
i'm the performer to my dying day will
stand by every word of my testimony
amber heard hitting back after johnny
depp's lawyer camille vasquez called her
testimony a performance
she spun a story of shocking
overwhelming brutal abuse
she came into this courtroom prepared to
give the performance of her life and she
gave it
while speaking to nbc news's savannah
guthrie in her first sit-down interview
since the trial amber shares her
reaction to the chaos that ensued for
some people
they just were frankly disgusted by the
whole thing and don't have much sympathy
for either one of you can you understand
that i would not blame the average
person for looking at this and how it's
been covered
and not think that it is
hollywood brats that they're at their
worst i'd
but
what people don't understand is it's
it's actually
so much bigger than that
this is uh
this is not only about
our first amendment right to speak but
savannah isn't having it and puts the
ball back in amber's court but here's
the thing about the first amendment the
first amendment protects free speech
it doesn't protect lies that amount to
defamation and that was the issue in the
case my understanding of what that means
is not just the freedom to speak
it's a freedom to speak truth to power
the truth is the word yes and that was
the issue and that's all i spoke
and i spoke it to power and i paid the
price at the end of the trial the jury
found that amber did in fact defame
johnny awarding him 15 million dollars
in damages but for amber she thinks
social media played a big part in
swaying the jury's decision i think the
vast majority of this trial was played
out on social media i think that this
trial
is an example of that gone
haywire gone amok and the jury is not
immune to that you think the jury saw it
how could they not i think even the most
well-intentioned juror
it would have been impossible to avoid
this after three and a half weeks i took
the stand
and saw just a courtroom packed
full
of captain jack sparrow fans but this
isn't the last we'll see of amber
because the source tells e.t this is
just the beginning amber was waiting a
bit before speaking out about the trial
and sharing her truth until she thought
ready and like it was a good time she
was advised by her team to lay low and
take time for herself but now that
amber's had time to process the verdict
well the source says she's feeling more
optimistic she is confident that her
side will come out eventually she has a
plan and strategy to make a comeback
over the next year do you stand by
your testimony and your accusations
against johnny depp about abuse of
course to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony
[Music]
you